so we have a cup we have a few different
updates from the whole Crowder Shapiro
[__] fight I guess slap fight I don't
know what we want to call this
uh the convection the the kaveching the
the covetching of 2023 the night of a
thousand kaveches yeah so anyways bro we
love markdite I'm going to tell you
something guys we pretty much love Mark
Dice around these parts uh we always
have we've goofed on them but always
playfully remember when he commented on
one of our hooks yeah but he's always
been a fun good sport and he's but he's
my God is he based so and he's
he was he's he's he's a weird case
he used to not be this based but he got
he got more bass this has been a a
journey for Mark like he's been getting
he used to be very good at hiding his
power levels and it's kind of he kind of
feels like um I don't know
well he feels like a kindred spirit
where he slowly over time was like these
[__] yeah pieces of [__] can't go to
buy a baby [__] gay liptuard all
right yeah just [__] record your
friends for 58 dog contract you're also
a Jew I hate both sides he is like I
love this man and I wish that was an
over-exaggeration but watch this
because I'm not Ben Shapiro who is
paying Facebook 135
000 a month every month on average to
fight big Tech by paying him 135 000 a
month boost his posts on Facebook just
for his Facebook page alone not for all
daily wire advertising so Shapiro Payne
Facebook 7.3 million dollars divided by
four and a half years note the dates
from May 18th through today okay so
that's 1.6 million a year or 135 000 a
month so it's no wonder Ben Shapiro is
the most popular political pundit on
Facebook this is publicly available
information by the way that Facebook
provides as part of their transparency
policy after a few Russians bought some
ads back in 2016. so who's in bed with
big Tech Ben Shapiro they're basically
married also as I met Mark and I'm with
the chat we brought this up grow a
mustache you need a monster we're not
goofing on you we seriously believe you
can pull a [__] mustache off I I
believe his stock will go up yes
probably 12 percent of you against
Mustang I'm telling you daddy says daddy
dice needs to come out yeah Mark as
somebody who tried and failed the
mustache you need a Mustang you need a
mustache buddy
basically married
yes yes as I mentioned it's just that
your upper lips a little weird it's too
thin and with a mustache you really will
it'll Alpha him up even more you will
come off very Alpha yeah you know like
what's the thing you learned about uh
when you're when you're doing like uh
filmmaking but filling negative space
yes exactly right oh they're basically
married also as I've mentioned numerous
times before Ben Shapiro had a secret
dinner with Mark Zuckerberg at least
listen I want every one of you tagging
Mark Dice on Twitter mustache and
telling them that our ROTC radio
told him he should grow a mustache
please and clip this if you want thank
you I want everyone bothering Mark
dicely grows a mustache no of and one of
Mark Zuckerberg's homes this is what
Stephen Crowder was alluding to
something I've been talking about for
years something that he never mentioned
before hashtag mustache for Mark
mustache I'm doing more Chris Jericho
again hashtag uh mustache for Mark
here's something that he never mentioned
before because he was in that inner
circle conservative Inc Club Glenn Beck
was also with Mark Zuckerberg that's
another fact that we know and since
we're on the topic people should also
know that Dave Rubin had a private
meeting with Youtube CEO Susan wojcicki
in 2019. he's conservative inc's token
gay guy so you know they're supporting
him so that he can keep making the
Republican Party more Progressive he's a
good friends by the way and this is why
I've always stayed independent because I
don't want some executive producer or
CEO telling me not to cover something or
not to criticize someone or no you have
no value if you can't all be kept in
line to some degree
I don't mean some master plan to
eliminate you just subdue you a little
bit just soften your edges a little bit
do you have play ball
and I like when you were
YouTube called you directly and asked
you to please stop selling a shirt that
you weren't even selling on YouTube you
were selling on your own website and you
play played ball a little yeah like that
just a little bit more let's throw a
couple T-shirts in the garbage the
Theatrical Theater kid [__] is so
[__] insufferable can you please just
talk like a [__] person no for once
in your life Crowder can you please just
be me he does he talks like a gay person
that's what a gay guy sounds like Bud
you never [__] went to school and met
a shrill gay [__] theater kid come on
what's what kind of [__] hick rural
[__] down did you go to school in you
know it's jarring about it it's that
there's no lisp it's like he trained to
get the lisp out of it yeah well Cody
Rhodes lost his too you can you can see
his speech there yeah you know what else
he lost his pectoral muscle
and his [__] world title run yeah
more
that's a good somebody said to be fair
he sold the mystery box with a shirt
does it matter he gave in it doesn't
matter what it was he gave in good point
Stephen but to be specific hold on stop
stop that's worse yeah that's [__]
worse because they [__] hit him up
and said hey we know what's in the
mystery box and he could have said oh
whatever do you mean he could [__]
what are you talking that's not a
[__] defense yeah oh soften your
edges a little bit just play ball a
little more
that's a good point Stephen but to be
specific since I never became friends
with any of the phonies in our movement
I don't have any dual loyalties I think
what you mean is anyone who signs a
contract with the daily wire The Blaze
Fox News Turning Point USA or Prager you
won't be allowed to criticize anything
Israel does to the Palestinians that's
anti-semitic or how the anti-bds laws
violate the First Amendment and they'll
be told not to talk about anti-whitism
or black crime especially using that
term and won't be allowed to denounce
gay marriage with too strong of language
or say that gay men adopting children or
buying them from fertility clinics and
using surrogates like Dave Rubin is
morally wrong
God damn Mark Dice he's the best [__]
yeah get him
uh I'm getting a poll going on Twitter
mustache mustache for uh for Martin good
good that's okay I'm glad that we all
you know we cut people people people
could stay you guys just sit there and
say whatever do whatever but I think you
guys are really trying to create change
you guys are really you make a
difference unlike some other people
online who call themselves Advocates you
guys actually go that extra mile to
create change and I'm just saying we
make if we get him
in a better position right then he'll
he'll gain more fans people to kill more
of it she's more of a Chad he can take
over the movement you know because who's
the other choice other than Dave Smith
Dave Smith's the only one he doesn't do
clubs
and that's a good time for us to
announce our new Coffee Company
Republican grind because we are always
on that we're on the Republican grind
yes did you know my abuela picks every
bag individually every Bean
to make it more coffee like I guess good
gimmick I can't start my morning without
some abuela roasted oh I'm sorry but my
base abuela makes Cafe Sito individually
for every one of our fans